President Trump is facing his first
international crisis and we know now no
he will not hesitate to use military
force to send a dramatic message to
series President Bashar Assad American
warships launched cruise missiles before
dawn local time the Pentagon hopes the
attack made it much harder for Syria's
President to use chemical weapons on his
own people US warships in the
Mediterranean Sea launched 59 missiles
they pound in an airbase in western
Syria the first video in from the scene
shows significant damage from the
missile attack the president explained
his decision late last night tonight I
ordered a targeted military strike on
the airfield in Syria from where the
chemical attack was launched Margaret
Brennan is with the president in Florida
Holly Williams is in Turkey but we begin
with David Martin he's at the Pentagon
David good morning good morning the u.s.
tried to avoid causing casualties but
there are reports of several dead
following the early morning strike the
Pentagon is still assessing the damage
but believes it knocked the base out of
commission the pentagon spokesman said
there is no need for further strikes
unless Syria once again resorts to
chemical weapons
[Music]
nearly 60 cruise missiles thundered
toward a Syrian Air Base just three days
after the regime used chemical weapons
in an attack against its own people
tomahawk land-attack missiles launched
from two destroyers the USS Porter and
USS Ross located in the eastern
Mediterranean Sea the strike targeted
sharat airfield believed to be the
take-off point of the plane that dropped
the lethal gas on a Syrian village
killing and injuring hundreds video from
Russian and Syrian state TV provided
footage of the aftermath of the attack
the missiles hit aircraft ammunition
depots air defense systems and air
traffic control radars the Pentagon said
the attack was successful and has
rendered the airfield unusable prior to
2013 the base located about 50 miles due
south of the location of the gas attack
had been used to store chemical weapons
but the u.s. did not target areas where
remaining weapons might be stored the
strike comes three and a half years
after former President Barack Obama
threatened military action against the
Assad regime a red line for us is we
start seeing a whole bunch of chemical
weapons moving around or being utilized
but despite threatening air strikes the
purpose of this strike would be to deter
Assad from using chemical weapons
President Obama backed off after Syrian
President Bashar al-assad promised to
hand over his stockpile of chemical
weapons a promise this week's attack
indicates the dictator did not keep
Russian personnel were located at the
base but the u.s. gave Russia advance
warning of the strike and the missiles
did not target areas where they were
believed to be living still russia's
President Putin is an ally of Assad and
the strike will almost certainly damage
us-russian relations Nora alright David
thank you